so the first day john cena saw me was my
first match i was on tv versus mason
ryan as a job guy i was gonna put him
over i was like yo i got a bar story i'm
gonna go home to the bar y'all pull up
that wrestling match i had dude [ __ ]
pull that [ __ ] up bro wait do you see
that oh hell yeah he got me one so i was
like yo i'm [ __ ] you know i didn't
think it was i was like yo i did it
though like i did it i got a match in
the wwe
so they give me the name enzo amore
which i had pitched for hell and high
water for that was the name i wanted
because my initials are ea so i was just
pitching names esteban apples anything
with a [ __ ] ea i was like just give
me ea they gave me enzo amore that's
what i want is that man i'm a big weed
guy right i meant one love to me i don't
know much about you know i ain't no
[ __ ] bilingual [ __ ] but i'm
speaking one language [ __ ]
money so anyway enzo amore one love
right first head of the house enzo in
time john cena is at the arena to keep
the house when we're in nxt you can't
keep people there you got four episodes
being filmed of tv you're gonna see the
same people more than once or twice and
they're gonna play out story lines that
are going on television in one night in
one night so you're getting like four or
five six hours of tapings and they're
taking all the rings off you'll never
forget bro who knows they're young and
the [ __ ]
you go out there at first and they have
like 12 ring canvases on because you
know somebody gets bloody somebody
sweats yeah they just take the canvases
off so if you're the guy in the first
match we would all be back there waiting
to hear the first big bump because dude
you're just slamming down on the hardest
dude like nine [ __ ] ring canvases you
know what i mean they haven't taken them
out yet by that time you're in the main
event there's one or two canvases there
so it's an easier bump yeah but that
first thud dawg that that first thought
was for real what the [ __ ] is this
you guys [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
you guys got a budget around here a
[ __ ] what dude a little [ __ ] super
glue right on it slides right on um
uh so
[ __ ] so cena was there to keep
everyone there because hey cena's gonna
be here so everyone's like we gotta stay
for seniors yeah yeah yeah but they
don't tell you that yeah so they're like
oh john cena's gonna be on the show and
you're sitting there for one hour two
hour three hour like when the [ __ ] is he
coming out clearly when the show's over
so that so john cena sees me go to the
ring and he's like
he he hears all the boys stand up in the
back and clap
so all the guys in the locker room are
clapping because i'm debuting and they
know that i'm the best on the mic and
i'm not getting an opportunity i have
never had a match and i'm debuting and
the coach wants me fired and dead
so they're like
outlaw [ __ ] they all stand up and clap
for me right and then that catches john
cena's attention he's like who the [ __ ]
why are you guys all clapping for this
[ __ ] and tyler breeze just
happened to be the guy who was standing
there that he asked and tyler bruce was
put us over to his credit thank you
tyler
tyler breeze is like yo these guys
talking about me and cass he's like cass
wasn't there i was debuting cass had not
done any nxt yet
they were saving them for whatever to
fire him or to put him on the moon
i'm going out there to get killed but
when i went out there i cut my shtick
and i said part of boomerang's kind of
room i don't right and [ __ ] john cena
stood up and set it back like bada boom
realest guy in the room
i don't know this is going on dude i
walk from the back i'm like oh god it's
all over i'm getting fired i feel like a
[ __ ] loser i just let that guy beat
my ass [ __ ] this shit's [ __ ]
for gays he's like i'm [ __ ] on it
i'm so mad at myself i'm like i just
lost like i just look like a loser i'm
getting fired whatever i did it right
and the [ __ ] kid comes running up to
me this kid rob naylor who worked
backstage as a producer and he's like
john cena wants to see you
so john cena asked me to get in the ring
with him not knowing i'm so green i
don't realize i booked my own [ __ ] i'm
like oh yeah that guy's my tag team
partner bro we were just me and cass
were just doing tag team uh promos for
dusty rhodes for like two three weeks
dusty liked it but we weren't by no
means a tag team but now i just tell
john cena he's my tag team partner he
goes get your [ __ ] and meet me backstage
and we're going out on the mics i'm like
what the [ __ ]
cass is bugging out we walked back there
triple h looked at us like what the [ __ ]
are you doing here john cena's a call
have them come out with me in the dark
segment now i just he just went over
triple h like and booked this [ __ ]
and i don't know what plans they had for
cash you know what i'm saying so now all
of a sudden i'm out there with gas well
we're intellectual savior of the masses
is damien sandow i loved sandy sandow's
awesome so sandow's cutting promos with
cena and he's supposed to be smart right
intellectual savior of the masses is
what they call him so that was why i
said he's seven foot tall and you can't
teach that because you know like you
smart guys
and then i said how many dimples are on
a golf ball you know when it dips on a
golf ball they're exactly 168 temples on
a golf ball you know how many dimples
are on my hind then zero you wanna know
why because i'm a hard body you know who
you are you're s-a-w-f-t
shuffed and [ __ ] john cena was like
what the [ __ ] did you just call him and
i was like shuffed
they they just the crowd repeated it now
the next time me and cass are on a show
i'm taking people's jackets i got a
merch uh i got a staff shirt on i'm
[ __ ] i'm not booked i don't get
booked again we go to the tv taping the
next one ryback's there in the dark
segment because he's feuding with john
cena right so his gimmick is feed me
more
me and cass
got summons five minutes before we had
to go through the curtain we're sitting
backstage and they're just going sure
sure
the crowd the crowd so they just call
[ __ ] five minutes like you're going
out with ryback in five minutes we're
like what so me and cass went out there
and we had to think of things to say his
gimmick was feed me more feed me more so
we were like you ladies are in the
meathead you got a real cheap date in
the ring right now all you got to do is
take them to the local golden corral you
guys know what you we're going to have
cash cash just rattled everything off on
the [ __ ] menu and i went hey dawn
how you doing
hey don and now the crowd's saying how
you doing so bro the first two times we
went out there we did soft and how you
doing and we haven't even been on tv yet
yeah so if you're at home in the uk or
you're watching nxt we come out for the
first time and you watch that orlando
crowd they go nuts but you don't know or
you're like who the [ __ ] now you've been
building that crowd why the [ __ ] but
they yeah we built that crowd in the
dark and then by that time that was our
crowd and uh
they just did whatever [ __ ] enzo and
cass wanted to do with us
i mean anything like we could have
farted in the microphone and they would
have been like yes that was [ __ ]
brilliant it was unreal so we just got
so lucky timing so cena had so much i
mean that's my [ __ ] wrestling story
that's where it ends
so i never figured out what the [ __ ] i
was doing after that